[Music]
the first time Nintendo tried to make a
movie things got bad I loved the Power
Glove it's so bad and the last time they
tried to adapt Mario thanks God weird
Yoshi is a pet of the royal family just
uh don't move your hands around like a
small wounded animal
now they'll give the minions team a shot
to turn it into the kids flick it was
always meant to be because doing the
most obvious thing possible is why we
love Nintendo in the first place
[Music]
have you played the newest one though he
can throw his hat now
[Music]
the Super Mario Brothers Super movie
say hello to Mario and Luigi the
original Super Mario Brothers
because Luigi spends the whole movie as
a hostage you will not be
ritualistically sacrifice Mario watch
comic Dynamo Charlie Day hang out in a
cage waiting to be rescued while funny
enough Chris Pratt repeatedly bails him
out of trouble
let's do what they say it's not easy
being day kick me around I'm like
probably the weirdest guy in the
universe you know probably even weirder
than someone from Saturn you loved him
as Andy Dwyer in parks and rec so now
we're stuck with Chris Pratt for all
eternity watch the Chris most likely to
do his own research reprise his
trademark role as a lone human bouncing
around an alien world listening to Dad
rock as he becomes Mario an icon to both
Italians and Gamers cause he's a hero
who still lives at home with his mom
he'll join up with Peach and honest to
goodness toilet baby who was flushed
into the Mushroom Kingdom one day and
somehow became the mother of fungus she
grew into a princess who's on board with
the concept of monarchy but won't accept
a marriage to save her kingdom because
she can't shake her mean case of human
savior syndrome
I will not let him hurt you he's not
[Applause]
him
well excuse me princess there's a
million toads and only one of you get a
grip and a loan for the ride our toad in
Donkey Kong portrayed by two comedians
whose voices are so unique they must be
used in everything forever
easy money
standing in their way is Bowser who asks
us to imagine what if Jack Black was
himself
I'll make you
he's got a fiendish plan to go viral on
Tick Tock he just peaches peaches
peaches peaches and with the Tenacious D
front man now part of Star Wars Nintendo
and Weird Al universes all in the same
year can every other franchise be far
behind
[Music]
sometimes you got to make some love
so grab the children for which this was
clearly meant for
enjoy the action that feels like
watching someone else play a video game
[Music]
embrace yourself for the Cinematic
Universe it's trying to jumpstart
there's a huge Universe out there with a
lot of galaxies in this Sugar Rush aimed
at the next generation of Nintendo Land
ticket buyers
if you're an adult seriously invested in
the quality of a Mario movie well they
put someone in this movie Just For You
everything's over now and all that's
left is you and the infinite void
story
I don't know what an Italian accent is
and at this point I'm too afraid to ask
KCF work the teachers of peaches you
know I could eat a peach for hours stool
sample do a barrel roll
retirement to the Planet of the Apes
your average Mario Maker level
[Music]
[Applause]
the character formerly known as look it
up and Einstein rosenbridge thanks Thor
what you seek it's a bridge like a good
night's Den Rosen Bridge more like a
Rainbow Bridge micro dosing
hey and more slow-mo than Zack Snyder
directing a Max Payne movie
[Music]
Super Cash Bros
Mario and Luigi are officially the best
characters to defend Brooklyn and
e-mushrooms the competition wasn't that
Fierce though I think that I may be the
voice of my generation
a Chris Pine Movie last week and now a
Chris Pratt movie this week can we just
lock all these quizzes up in a jail cell
already and see which one comes out
alive we basically did exactly that in
an all-new episode of by the Numbers
where Pine Pratt Hemsworth and Evans
fight to see who's put up the most
impressive movie stats for Chris's enter
one Chris leads click the Box on the
right to watch now
love really makes a guy come out of his
shell hard man part machine hard bird
hard drum it's Robo Bongo cuckoo cob
millions of peaches peaches for me
peaches peaches oh yeah